l'établissement réputé depuis 1958 mais
de moins en moins à la hauteur des
attentes
c'est justement pour conserver cette
réputation et demeurer concurrentielle
que le reine elizabeth se refait une
beauté
on maintient nos occupations et nos
tarifs
comment l'eau ou le rythme mais on peut
pas se permettre de rien faire pour
encore bien des années
le propriétaire de l'hôtel ivanhoé
cambridge investir à 140 millions de
dollars pour y faire des travaux majeurs
l'importance du chantier fort sa
fermeture pendant un an soit 2 juin 2016
à juin 2017
il va nous éviter les désagréments vécus
au château frontenac à québec
c'est difficile pour les opérations de
recevoir des gens chez vous lorsque du
bruit lorsque de la poussière les
visiteurs accéderont à lutter pendant
cette période la façade et les premiers
étages seront complètement transformée
pour devenir un campus d'affaires une
idée signée ces deux lits et la moitié
des 9 150 chambres seront modernisés
l'autre moitié
suivra alors que l'hôtel sera
partiellement ouvert et pour les
amateurs la chambre où s'est tenu le
bed-in de john et yoko la 1742 sera
réservée dommages collatéraux à venir
toutefois montréal se retrouvera pendant
une année
avec près de 1000 chambres d'hôtel en
moins éventuellement la réputation de
montréal comme lieu de tourisme vous
gagne l'été 2016 ça reset un été ou au
mieux réserver d'art ans mais l'impact
le plus dur 600 personnes seront mises à
pied temporairement sans indemnité on
prévoit qu'il va y avoir plus d'emplois
dans l'hôtel à la réouverture qui en eau
en ce moment l'yonne convention
collective aussi qui prévoit des
processus de rappel les employés ont
appris la nouvelle
aujourd'hui et leur syndicat attend de
voir leurs réactions avant de se
prononcer un communiqué sera émis
vendredi
et si mathieu guillon radio canada
montréal
oui